the story of irwin smith the demon
commander
as a child irwin was a curious and
insightful individual who did not accept
facts at face value he asked why
humanity had no memory of what happened
before they lived within the walls
because even if they had lost all of
their records the first generation
should have been able to teach their
children his father shared a theory with
him that the king had altered humanity's
memories when they first entered the
walls so he could control them better
too innocent to realize why his father
would not discuss this in the classroom
irwin shared it with the other kids in
town which resulted in his father's
accidental death arranged by the
military police brigade's first interior
squad irwin later enlisted in the
training court where he became friends
with nile dock with whom he shared his
theory about the royal government hiding
the truth about the world after
graduating irwin joined the survey corps
where he stopped sharing his theory with
others he realized that everyone else
was fighting for the sake of humanity
whereas he was only fighting for himself
nonetheless he thrived as a soldier and
eventually was given subordinates under
his command while a squad leader irwin
devised the long-distance enemy scouting
formation as a way to minimize
casualties while on expeditions his
proposal was rejected by then-commander
keith shadis who told him to try when he
became commander himself although his
proposal had been rejected irwin began
implementing his strategies in his own
squad and over time other soldiers and
the populace began to notice that his
squad would take no casualties whereas
shadis would often be the only survivor
of his charges in the year 845 irwin
takes part in an expedition beyond wall
maria when the expedition returns shadis
requests that irwin take over as
commander of the survey corps in the
year 850 irwin leads an expedition
beyond wall roads while the survey corps
is clearing a town inside walmarea it's
discovered the titans are moving north
towards the tross district of walrose
and irwin orders a retreat fearing a
breach the survey corps head to tross
district and narrowly save a trapped
aaron armin and mikasa after their
mission to block the hole is complete
irwin next appears when aaron recovers
from his three-day coma and is kept in a
jail cell beneath the military court he
explains to aaron that his titan powers
have caused an uproar within the walls
he has taken the key to aaron's basement
and asks if the secret to titans is
located in the basement to which aaron
replies that he believes so aaron then
formulates a plan to use aaron's titan
form to retake wal-maria so they can
investigate the basement irwin attends
the military's tribunal to determine
what to do with aaron jaeger proposing
to the military's commander-in-chief
darry exactly that the boy be entrusted
to the survey corps so that his powers
can be used to reclaim wal-maria in the
middle of the trial aaron loses his
temper prompting levi to beat him in
front of everyone to prove that he can
be controlled seizing the opportunity
irwin promises that he will station
aaron under levi if he is allowed to
join the survey corps ensuring that he
will be kept under control additionally
to keep wall's civilians calm he agrees
to hand aaron over to the military
police if the boy proves to be a failure
on his first expedition satisfied with
erwin's proposal zachary hands aaron
over to the corps after the trial irwin
and some of his officers meet with aaron
privately irwin apologizes to aaron for
levi's treatment of him before
commending him for unwittingly giving
them the perfect argument to convince
the military to turn him over to the
court finally welcoming him to the
survey corps after the death of the
titan research subjects bean and sunny
he tests everyone in the survey core by
asking them a direct but confusing
question to gauge the reactions when
this proves that everyone is innocent he
begins planning the next expedition to
capture the spy guessing they have
abilities similar to aaron and are
intent on sabotaging the expedition
irwin later appears at the recruitment
drive where the 104th training corps
choose their path he makes an
impassioned plea that the survey court
and aaron represent the hope of humanity
although he is very realistic in telling
them that a sizable number of them will
die during his speech irwin makes public
that they will get to the basement and
maybe will find clues that may free them
of domination by titans which makes
armin think that he must have an agenda
his speech and other factors succeed in
recruiting every remaining member of the
top 10 graduates except annie who joins
the military police brigade irwin leads
the 57th expedition out of cadanes
district on a mission to reach
shinganshina district and potentially
uncover the secret of aaron's basement
shortly after the survey corps reaches
open territory outside wall rows he
orders them into a long distance enemy
scouting formation despite the
dissemination of the formation's right
flank by an abnormal titan irwin
continues the operation to the surprise
of his soldiers he directs them to a
titan forest where the central column
containing the carts and the special
operations squad are to follow him
inside while the rest of the formation
surrounds the forest perimeter to
prevent the entry of any additional
titans understanding that the abnormal
titan destroying his ranks is
intelligent irwin plans to deal with it
inside the special operation squad leads
the female titan into irwin's trap where
he orders the firing of the special
target restraining weapon this allows
the survey court to successfully capture
it when levi and mike try to cut through
the female titans hands to the nape
irwin notes that it can selectively
harden its body similar to what he has
heard about the armor titan he decides
that the court does not have enough time
to see if the titan will weaken under
repeated assaults and calls kg over to
prepare explosives to blow off the
female titans hands at the wrists to
avoid killing the person inside before
that can happen the female titan screams
and mike alerts irwin to multiple titans
approaching from all directions erwin
sends the cart team to intercept the
first wave of titans but they ignore the
soldiers and break through he realizes
that they are after the female titan and
orders the court to defend it however
they are overwhelmed and unable to keep
up the female titan is torn to pieces
and erwin calls the soldiers to retreat
and return to karenas as irwin watches
the titans devour what remains of the
female titan he had meets to levi that
he did not expect their enemy would be
willing to sacrifice themselves the
steam emitting from the remains the
female titan causes him to think of the
colossus titan which had also vanished
in a cloud of steam before levi can call
back his team irwin tells him to refill
his gas and blades hanji questions the
order while they ride out of the forest
because they cannot spare the time and
erwin explains that though the female
titan has been eaten he cannot say the
same for the person inside he expects
that their enemy has regained human form
and is now able to move around if they
also equip vertical maneuvering
equipment then they are likely wearing
the survey core uniform and are
camouflaged as a fellow soldier irwin
thinks it was a mistake to have based
their assumption of the female titan's
abilities on aaron who is a complete
novice when it comes to his power he
leads the court back into careness where
they are greeted by grumbles of wasted
taxes and demands for justification for
the number of dead because of the
expedition's failure irwin is summoned
to the capital to hand over aaron before
they depart for the capital armin shares
his suspicion with irwin that annie
lonehart is the female titan irwin
orders her covert capture and route to
the meeting after arriving in stowa's
district and fighting breaks out against
the female titan he's questioned by nile
dog who orders his troops to support the
operation she's eventually apprehended
and irwin goes into an emergency meeting
held to sort out the day's events
admitting that the corps was unable to
get any information out of annie before
she sealed herself away inside of a
hardened crystal irwin requests that
he'd be allowed to track down any allies
annie might have hidden in the military
the meeting is interrupted when a core
soldier thomas bursts in to inform them
that titans have been spotted inside
wall rose by the next day irwin's forces
arrive in tross district where he meets
up with dot pixes pixes congratulates
him for finding one of their mice even
though the plan did not succeed as well
as hoped now those in the interior will
reconsider their motives and beliefs
irwin says they have the military police
have been forced to come out and help
fight against the titans irwin is
present when phil reports to pixas about
having met up with hanji's unit on top
of wall rose he hears that an additional
three trainees of the 104th can change
into titans and asks what happened when
their forms were revealed phil tells him
the corps engaged the colossus and
armored titans but the battle was over
by the time phil's unit was able to join
the combined military force rides along
the top of wall rows and when they meet
up with hanji's unit irwin has them
deploy the lips to carry the horses down
to the ground on the outside of the wall
though badly injured hanji gets a map
and shows urban where a titan forest is
hanji suspects reiner and bertolt have
gone there when erwin asks her why she
explains that even though they can
change into titans they probably are
exhausted and will need to rest
somewhere ordinary titans are not able
to reach them before making a run for
the outside of wall maria the survey
corps will only have until nightfall
when other titans cannot move irwin
leads the combined military force into a
long-range scouting formation as they
head for the forest when titans begin to
approach from the right flank irwin has
the formation pull in on that side
rather than change direction as they
can't afford to lose any time as titans
continue to approach irwin tries to
maneuver the formation but they end up
being hemmed in on both sides as well as
ahead of them deciding it would take too
much time to make a detour erwin orders
the soldiers to force their way through
they arrive as the sun is setting and
when they see the light from a titan
transformation inside the forest irwin
notes that they have arrived in time he
has the soldiers dispersed to locate and
recover the kidnapped aaron irwin spots
the armored titan escaping at the edge
of the force and calls for all squads to
follow him and let the titans chase
after them he leads the military
straight at reiner with all the titans
on their collective tail knowing that
the titans will be just as happy to
attack the armored titan he shouts for
all soldiers to disperse and get away
leaving reiner to deal with the brunt of
the titan attention once reiner is
immobilized beneath the weight of all
the other titans irwin calls for the
soldiers to attack because they must
recover aaron if humanity is to have a
future as he leads the charge a titan
unexpectedly appears in their midst
catching his arm in its mouth erwin
shouts for the soldiers to continue
their advance as it carries him away he
returns to the battle as armin is
baiting bertolt and reiner into losing
control and he takes the opportunity to
cut aaron free of berthold as well as
severing one of bertolt's grappling
lines with aaron retrieved erwin bellows
for all soldiers to retreat reiner
begins throwing titans at the fleeing
soldiers and irwin is knocked from his
horse as emir takes out the titan
chasing him when a survey corps soldier
tries to help him irwin insists that he
is replaceable retreating with aaron is
their top priority the battle turns
against the military as the soldiers are
hemmed in and the armored titan recovers
enough strength to begin moving again
aaron strikes a titan attacking him and
mikasa triggering something that causes
all the other mindless titans present to
tear it apart the titans then go and
attack reiner and bertolt as well seeing
the opportunity for escape irwin shouts
for the soldiers to withdraw despite the
loss of his arm irwin is in good spirits
when hanji and connie springer report on
the supposed breach of wall rose and the
fate of ragako village connie's home
despite the evidence that the village
buildings had exploded from the inside
there was no blood found in addition to
finding no survivors the number of
titans discovered inside wall rose was
equal to the population of ragako hanji
theorizes the titans are humans pointing
out the fact that the weak point of
titans correlates to the spinal cord of
a human since erwin has been out of
commission levi informs him that he has
taken the liberty of recruiting his new
squad consisting of armin connie aaron
historia jean mikasa and sasha after his
recovery irwin arrives in the capital to
answer a summons by the chancellery on
the way there he meets with now doc who
is guarded about the reason erwin called
him irwin asks if nile knew that
minister nick was tortured to death by
the military police's interior first
squad finding nile unaware and
disinclined to think for himself irwin
brings up niall's wife marie and warns
nile that protecting his job is not the
same as protecting his family
unsatisfied with the results of his
summons irwin meets with dot pixes and
proposes that the military stays a coup
d'etat he recounts the events of his
childhood and how his father was killed
for getting close to a truth the
government wanted to be hidden based on
his father's theories and the evidence
they have gained concerning the titans
the walls and aaron's powers erwin
concludes that 107 years ago the
memories of humanity were altered to
erase knowledge of the outside world
after returning to the survey corps
headquarters in tross district irwin is
informed that the interior first squad
is looking for him in regard to an
organized murder irwin appoints hanji
the next commander of the survey court
should anything happen to him and heads
outside to meet the military police the
survey corps is blamed for the death of
demo reeves and irwin is taken away
despite its persistent defense of the
survey corps even in the face of the
interior military police's questioning
erwin's words fall on deaf ears his
audience with the king goes poorly and
the nobles reveal that levi has killed
several members of the military police
brigade they declare that there is need
to tolerate such a group as the survey
corps within the walls this heart and
erwin realizes that he has done all he
could and there's only one gambit left
the order is given to take him to the
gallows as he is being escorted from the
room anka bursts in and announces that
the colossus titan and armored titan
have breached wall rose refugees are
already on their way to walchina pixas
reacts immediately calling for soldiers
to secure an evacuation route which
causes the officials in the room to
revere their true colors when they give
the order to shut the gates to wall
sheena sacrificing half of humanity nile
doc throws his lot in with wall rose as
does commander in chief zackly who
arrives with group of armed soldiers and
announces that the panic was just the
fabrication the announcement was a test
by pixis to see if the aristocracy is
worthy of ruling of the human race now
all heads of the military are against
them after the proclamation that the
military has seized control of the
capital irwin departs in a carriage with
zackly he expresses second thoughts
about having deposed the monarchy
regardless of their corruption and
selfishness humanity had survived this
long under their guardianship exactly
tells him that he threw his lot in with
the coup because of an intense desire to
humiliate the king and his men and he
had planned to eventually give it a try
with or without owen after a moment's
thought irwin admits that his reason is
for a childhood dream in the evening
irwin meets up with pixis and anka at a
military barracks filled with waiting
survey corps soldiers to head to reese
chapel pixis informs irwin that the
government leaders say the same thing
that the reece family has the ability to
alter human memory proving correct the
theory that erwin and his father had
however pixes disagrees both with
zachary's fondness for torture and
erwin's own pension for risk it bothers
pixas that if the crown had been worthy
he would have fought against zackly
instead irwin remarks that people will
not stop fighting each other until the
population is one or less which amuses
pixas enough to lighten his mood on the
way to rhys chapel irwin and the survey
court encounter a giant titan crawling
face down on the ground it's hot enough
to ignite trees and irwin orders his
soldiers to get back and evacuate any
nearby civilians one of the survey corps
members reports that squad levi is here
having successfully rescued aaron and
historia irwin rides over to them and
finds out that only hanji is hurt and
not too badly levi informs irwin that
the giant titan is rod reese and aaron's
scream is not working to stop him so the
survey corps falls back to orva district
to prepare fighting it using the
civilian population as bait when the
garrison pushes back hanji explains that
this particular titan is so abnormal
that if the citizens are evacuated
inside walchina it will likely ignore
overt entirely and break through the
wall eventually arriving at the capital
mitras which would be a disaster
despite the risk to civilians irwin
pledges to do everything they can to
prevent the loss of any non-combatants
and suggests an emergency evacuation
drill to be held so people will be
prepared to leave should the need come
the titan arrives at dawn and the
opening cannon volley by the garrison
does little to slow rod despite being
the best effort orva could scrape
together but erwin still has a strategy
hanji brings out barrels of gunpowder
ropes and a net to form a blunt weapon
like stuffing a sock full of rocks and
moblet wheels out a barrel of gunpowder
strapped to a cart and modified with
vertical maneuvering gear to reel itself
into its target finding historia among
the soldiers present irwin expresses his
concern for her being on the front lines
since she will become queen if they
survive undeterred historia asks if he
thinks people are naive enough to follow
someone who is a ruler only in name she
has her own mission she intends to carry
out irwin disapproves but admits that
due to his missing an arm he can't stop
her though the garrison's repeated
shelling eventually exposes the giant
titan's nape the wind changes before
they can finish it off rod clings to the
wall and begins to pull himself over it
exposing his titan's face for the first
time it is sheared off from the pressure
of being dragged across the ground and
the mouth is hanging open the survey
corps sends the garrison away and douses
themselves in water to withstand the
heat from rod's body as they enact
irwin's plan at a signal they fire the
gunpowder loaded carts into rod's hands
throwing him off balance and allowing
aaron to run up in his titan form aaron
throws the net full of gunpowder barrels
into the massive titan's mouth and the
entire package explodes due to the sheer
heat of the titan
large chunks of the titan fly into the
air and irwin calls for soldiers to
finish it off since the titan will
regenerate if the nape is not destroyed
historia is the one to find the correct
piece thus killing her father two months
after historia has been crowned as queen
technology has progressed thanks to
research that was preserved by the
interior military police the shining
stones found on the reece family grounds
and aaron's new hardening abilities this
allows new weapons to be created that
allow soldiers to kill titans without
taking risks
with the success of the executioner from
hell erwin tells zackly and the other
heads of the military that the survey
corps is preparing for the retaking of
shiganshina and that preparations will
be ready in the month after the meeting
erwin pixar's hanji levi and zachary
have a private meeting they talk about
the serum that kenny gave levi hanji
explains that analyzing it is impossible
because the fluid evaporates in contact
with air pixis then decides that it must
be used for the purpose it was made for
to allow a human to become a titan and
then take the power of the titans irwin
decides to entrust the vile to levi
because he is their strongest soldier
with the highest chance of survival levi
will have the freedom to use it based on
his judgment of the situation
in the trust district the survey court
head members are having a meeting about
keith shattuck's revelation erwin
listens as hanji explains that grisha
jaeger had the power of the titans from
outside the walls they then discussed
why grisha did not speak of the
information he had to the survey court
but also committed the killing of the
rhys family the day while maria fell
they theorized about what may be hidden
in the basement of grisha's house as
irwin suggests that it may be the
memories of the world that the reece
family tried to erase irwin then
announces that the operation to retake
wall maria is ready and will commence in
two days promising to see the basement
when the meeting ends levi closes the
door behind the other members and begins
to warn irwin he tries to convince him
with the threat of breaking his legs to
stay behind in the trust district due to
the fact that he's missing an arm and
will make him tighten food especially on
the front lines however erwin confesses
that seeing what is in the basement is
more important to him than living and
that he must be there to see this moment
for humanity after hearing this levi
gives up and realizes that he will
unfortunately not be able to change the
commander's mind the day of the
operation all soldiers are ready at dawn
erwin and other high-ranking soldiers
salute to members of the other branches
and head to the wall however the
soldiers are surprised after seeing that
the civilians know about the operation's
goals and start to cheer for them irwin
seeing the best sends off the survey
corps has ever received cheers a loud
scream back at them as he raises his one
arm into the air leaving a subordinate
surprise for this unusual reaction he
then orders the start of the operation
and the members of the survey corps
start their paths towards shiganshina
district as irwin leads them upon
arriving at shiganshina irwin commands
the soldiers to switch to vertical
maneuvering equipment and rush the gate
irwin is aware that their enemies know
about the operation to seal the wall and
investigate the basement so he has 100
soldiers covered by their hoods rush the
gate so that the enemy will be unable to
know which soldier is aaron until he has
sealed the gate the corps becomes wary
of the complete lack of titans in the
area but they choose to continue with
the mission anyway aware they are
playing into the enemy's hands the core
stand by and prepare for the closing of
the wall as aaron flies up above the
gate and prepares to transform after
aaron seals the breach in the southern
gate of walmarea armin informs the
commander of the remains of a campsite
atop the wall as well as cold cups lying
on the ground irwin rightly speculates
that the enemy had foreseen their
arrival and gives armin authority over
an investigation of the wall just after
reiner is found within the wall and
unsuccessfully attacked by captain levi
erwin spots the beast titan and a horde
of other titans from beyond the northern
gate the beast titan launches a rock at
shiganshina's inner gate and traps the
survey corps horses outside making
escape into the district impossible this
begins a war and erwin states that only
one of them the humans or the titans
will leave alive as reiner begins
climbing the wall irwin orders the
soldiers to avoid engaging with him as
he surveys the beast titans forces irwin
notices a quadruple titan carrying
luggage on its back and theorizes that
it was the scout that warned the other
warriors of the corps arrival as the
beast titan's forces begin attacking
irwin predicts that they will attack the
core's horses next in order to
completely remove any option of a
retreat irwin orders dirk marlene and
their squads to join with klaus squad in
protecting the horses north of the
district hanji and levi squads to engage
the armored titan and orders levi to
attack the beast titan directly and kill
it as he observes the battle from atop
wall maria irwin notes the core's lack
of manpower prompting him to reflect on
the lives lost under his command being
sent to their debts for his own
ambitions of proving his father's
theories of the outside world right
although he feels some guilt irwin
quickly turns his attention towards
aaron's basement and begins trying to
work out a way to reach it even if the
corps are defeated in battle from atop
the wall he witnesses bertolt being
thrown into the district by zeke as well
as his subsequent transformation into
the colossus titan seeing the colossus
titan irwin questions if everything is
going according to the beast titans plan
when zeke begins assaulting the survey
corps to the north with a barrage of
stones and boulders irwin orders their
retreat and joins with them at the base
of the wall irwin informs captain levi
of their desperate situation having lost
many of their soldiers as well as their
advantage in the battle as the new
recruits descend into a panic levi asked
the commander if he has any more ideas
seeing the inevitable defeat of the
survey corps irwin begins to grieve over
the failure of his attempts to learn the
truth of the world he thinks back on the
many soldiers that died for the sake of
humanity levi decides to make the choice
of action on irwin's behalf irwin must
give up on his dreams and die with the
recruits while levi battles the beast
titan despite his dreams coming to a
bitter end irwin is relieved standing
before the panicked recruits irwin
announces their plan to charge head on
against the beast titan using smoke
signals as cover while levi moves in
from the side to confront him using the
line of titans as a mean of clearing the
distance the recruits are distraught at
the plan asking if it is even worth the
effort if they'll die anyway irwin
admits that the decision of the recruits
to fight or abandon their duties are
meaningless but the lives of the
soldiers who will die are not without
meaning he declares that it is the duty
of the living to give meaning to the
dead and that they must carry out their
duty in a way that the living will give
their own deaths meaning using smoke
signals as cover they charge the beast
titan head on with battle cries charging
into the fray irwin urges the soldiers
to let their blood boil to let their
voices be heard and fight after the
first barrage of rox's throne irwin is
struck and a rock flies through the left
side of his waist and through his
horse's head and neck irwin manages to
survive the hit but is left unconscious
and mortally wounded he is found by
flock who carries him back to
shiganshina district upon arriving the
realization that irwin is still alive
causes a conflict between the remaining
soldiers who are divided on whether to
save him or armin with the only titan
injection that they have after a scuffle
with aaron and mikasa levi is about to
give irwin the serum when he remembers
erwin's desire to give up his dreams and
die with the recruits killed earlier
levi gives armin the serum instead
allows him to eat bertolt and tells
irwin that there will be a delay in his
promise to kill the beast titan as erwin
dies peacefully
click on this video to learn everything
about levi ackermann humanity's
strongest soldier